so congratulations in the film it was
really really great I literally couldn't
look away from the screen the whole time
so much were you a fan of the Bourne
series before and how was it going into
like established franchise like that I
think it was mid teenager when I saw the
first film and it was actually even I
first moved to London I had some
girlfriends that I lived with and we had
the box with the trilogy that we watched
over and over again so I I was just
actually really excited when I found out
that Matt Damon and Paul Greengrass were
gonna team up again and make another one
and that was before I was part of it
myself so I was really really excited
did you get any advice from fellow Oscar
Matt Damon without being on set I mean
it's well I think on any film working
with brilliant actors it's it's more
about he's he's like the warmest most
down-to-earth person and then he's such
a hard worker and it's more about you
know looking and in getting to watch
somebody in action and I I just admire
him for being so kind of on it and and
and give it all in each scene and and
then he will so as soon as their take is
over he's probably the person with the
most energy and the biggest smile and
it's also about kind of bringing
everyone together not only cast but also
crew your character Heather Lee plays a
spy which is clearly like the coolest
job in the world if you could spy on any
famous person for a whole day who'd it
be if I was a spy I don't know I would
be maybe want maybe on Heatherly she
seems to have a very hidden agenda maybe
I would try and figure out where that
was you've clearly got a really busy
yeah for films out so if you could take
six month break right now what would you
do with that I think I would love to I
would love to go skiing and I would my I
probably will go there for the first
time with this film actually I'm so
excited we're gonna go to Japan it's
been a country I've always wanted to go
to and they apparently have great scheme
to maybe come combine them too so we're
also really excited about Tomb Raider
which is out next year
did you by chance ask the former Lara
Croft for any advice Angelita
oh I haven't I would love to meet Angie
and just tell her how much I adored her
in those films and I mean when I heard
about the project itself the first I was
like well it's been done and she's wolf
always be you know that she's the woman
you think about when you hear Lara Croft
but they did reboot the game around 2013
two of them have come out so it is more
of a origin story and and quite a
different take on it lassic glamour
we're really into books so we're asking
are there any recent books that you've
read and loved recently when breath
becomes air it's a very good book that's
out now why do you love that book it's a
story about life and and and and love
and loss and all the kind of you know
big things in life and yeah